KEVIN MOORE: You guys
have a good lunch?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KEVIN MOORE: I love having
the slot right after lunch.
DAN GROVE: Right after
lunch is perfect.
KEVIN MOORE: Everyone's
sufficiently caffeinated.
Hopefully last 30 minutes
has all been coffee.
Dan, we have three things
to talk about today.
DAN GROVE: That's right.
So what's number one?
Number one, Dart for Web
is here to embrace the web
rather than replace the web.
KEVIN MOORE: Right,
despite all the rumors.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
KEVIN MOORE: The second thing
is we've an amazing tooling
story that we think will make
you amazingly productive.
And three--
DAN GROVE: We have a
great framework story.
It'll make you even
more productive.
KEVIN MOORE: Yes,
so let's dig in.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KEVIN MOORE: So perfect.
You guys already with us?
All right.
So let's talk about
where we have this,
you know, set of
three things going on,
so we have three things
around embracing the web.
One is it's JavaScript
all the time.
The second is embracing
great canonical JavaScript
and having a great
interop story.
So Dan, tell us
about JavaScript.
DAN GROVE: Let's talk a little
bit about how we got here.
You guys may have
heard that we had
a slight change in direction
in the last couple of months.
Right?
We've been pushing hard
to put the VM in Chrome.
And while we were
doing that we actually
noticed that a lot of stuff
had changed on the web,
so JavaScript engines
have been getting faster.
Where all kinds of neat features
going into things like ES6.
And so we sat back and we really
rethought what the approach
we're taking was.
And we decided that rather
than targeting the VM in Chrome
we're going to target,
essentially, all the world's
modern browsers.
And actually they're
all amazingly good.
Things have gotten
so much better
since we started the project.
Go ahead.
KEVIN MOORE: So I
think you know--
besides being the voice of God.
Wow that's amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
Talk about speaking with
authority right now.
So yeah, it's two things.
One is this is the
notion that for web apps,
we realized that the
cost of a VM in Chrome
meant a lot of things.
Our users would have to
deploy two sets of code, Dart
and JavaScript.
You have to worry
about interop stories.
And it meant that our Dart story
for the broad set of browsers,
which most people would
have to target anyway,
made a whole set of
things complicated.
And so we realized it's a
great simplifying assumption
for what the Dart team provides
and for our customers provide.
And it lets us do a
lot of great things
that we're excited
to talk about.
DAN GROVE: It was
also something-- whoa.
It was also something
that kind of
scared our users when they
realized that their development
path and their deployment
paths were so divergent.
You know it was--
it really left them
without the degree of confidence
that we wanted to give them.
KEVIN MOORE: Right.
And it lets us do cool things.
For instance, we'll
still support this notion
of a tree shaking, globally
analyzed, globally inferred
output-- so you can give
one small output file.
But we're also going to
add the option for you
to generate
canonical JavaScript.
So the idea is one Dart library
will produce one JavaScript
file.
That output JavaScript
will be readable.
It'll be debuggable--
like basically a one
to one correspondence.
And it'll enable really
fast compilation.
Because each library will
have a canonical output,
and will not require us
to do global inference,
that means if you change
a library we don't have
to recompile your whole app.
We'll need to recompile
the bits that you changed
DAN GROVE: Yeah,
so we're talking
about sub second recompilation.
KEVIN MOORE: Right.
And we can leverage
things, hopefully,
like multi cores
and other things.
So again for the
deployment you probably
still want to have a large,
globally inferred tree shaking
output.
But during development
we're hoping
that we can give you a
much faster turn around
for your code, and give you a
much better debugging story.
Because obviously just working
on Chrome is not enough.
We all care about
supporting multiple browsers
and being sure that Dart works
across all those experiences.
As an example--
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
So let's talk about
the dev compiler, which
is our current internal
working name that we're
using for this kind of
lightweight JavaScript
compilation.
This code may look
familiar to some of you.
This is the world's
best sample program.
It's from Sunflower, which
I know we know and love
on the Dart team.
It's a sample that we've shipped
for an awfully long time.
KEVIN MOORE: So
its canonical Dart.
And actually we've made this
sample a little bit more
complicated than we
ship with the editor.
So we actually use mixins here.
You see we're using Cascades.
Canonical Dart code.
And this is the
exact same output
with our new dev compiler.
DAN GROVE: It looks
very similar actually.
KEVIN MOORE: So the
few things-- one
is because we're targeting
development time for our dev
compiler, this means we
can actually assume things
like the latest ES6 features.
So what we're
targeting is basically
things that are not behind flags
in Chrome as our output model.
So that you end up
with really-- you
know we use things like class
and extends that exist in ES6.
And this is very
debuggable JavaScript.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
One way to think about this
is the competition for dev
compiler today is Dartium.
And so right now everyone
does their web development
using-- in Dartium and so that
has the latest Chrome features.
And we're really imagining
that people would--
who are using the dev
compiler would just
develop with tip
of Chrome and use
the on flagged features there.
KEVIN MOORE: Right.
So our plan in the short
term is we'll continue
to ship Dartium and support it.
We know it's critical
for you folks.
And our goal is on the slide
really ramping this up,
which means we'll have a great
development story and debugging
story in JavaScript.
And our goal is to
hit the same refresh
cycle, the same
productivity you have
currently in Dartium,
but in a completely
100% JavaScript model.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
We will not rest until we're
at sub-second refresh with dev
compiler.
KEVIN MOORE: And there's people
here working on dev compiler
now.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
Did VJ actually sit down?
KEVIN MOORE: No.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN GROVE: So--
KEVIN MOORE: He's
a technical lead.
We've a number of other folks
working on the dev compiler
here.
And again, this is kind
of our proving ground.
And we hope to roll most of
these features into Dart JS.
So we'll still have a one--
a single tool chain model
eventually, right now we have
a separate project, basically
making [INAUDIBLE].
But we can do other
things besides just
generate beautiful JavaScript.
Right?
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
I noticed when we sat down for
the Birds of a Feather session
that there were a vast number
of questions about JS Interrupt.
I also noticed that
on the moderator page,
there were a ton of
questions about JS Interop.
KEVIN MOORE: It's
like people care
about using existing JavaScript
code for some reason.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
I mean I wasn't kidding.
Someone asked there at
the [INAUDIBLE] session
like how you move
a project piecemeal
from Dart to JavaScript.
And I said, well you know
the old style approach was
that we told you
step one was RM-RF
and then you could start
typing your Dart project.
And we found that was actually a
kind of large barrier to entry.
KEVIN MOORE: Right.
And so our idea
is basically this.
And what's great is you
know-- Google has actually
been on the forefront of type
JavaScript for a long time.
Actually my gateway drug to Dart
was the Closure Compiler set
of tools five years ago.
And so we have a great
set of typed interfaces
to existing JavaScript libraries
through the closure tools.
And obviously TypeScript
and definitely
typed it on [? Org ?].
Did a bunch of work additionally
to add typed interfaces
to existing JavaScript tools.
So our goal here-- again,
this is nothing to show today,
but I think Jacob will hint
to some of these things
later tonight.
Is that you can go from one
of these type interfaces,
actually create a stub library
that looks and feels like Dart
code, that the analyzer will
work against to get completion
and errors and warnings.
And then use that
and actually generate
Dart code that interops very
cleanly with JavaScript.
DAN GROVE: Exactly.
And then we have a
longer term goal,
which is we also want to be able
to take a nice annotated Dart
library and export it in a good
usable way as a JS library.
So the goal here is
that we want to enable
component vendors, who are
building stuff in Dart,
to be able to ship
those components
as nice, readable JavaScript
without a ton of libraries,
so that they can
actually vend them out
to people, whether
those consumers are
using Dart or JavaScript.
So we think that will open
the market significantly
for people building
components in Dart.
KEVIN MOORE: What's great is
we can be super smart about how
we generate that JavaScript.
So things like documentation
tools for JavaScript
and things-- we can generate
the right JavaScript so
that documentation just works.
Your customer
shouldn't have to know
that you wrote your component
in Dart, except that they
want to have the great
development experience that you
had.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
So funnily enough someone
was asking me this morning
about d3 versus charted.
I see [INAUDIBLE] back there.
And it wasn't him, but
it wouldn't surprise me
if he would ask me about this.
And what you can see
on the upper left here
is a use of d3 in JavaScript.
And it looks sort of OK.
And if you were using current
Dart JS Interop package
you would see a vast
amount of boilerplate.
But what you can see
on the lower right
is the work of Jacob Richmond.
Where is he?
KEVIN MOORE: Is he here?
DAN GROVE: No,
he's not even here.
KEVIN MOORE: He's out working
on his lightning talk right now.
DAN GROVE: Exactly.
But it's work that he did
recently on JavaScript Interop.
And the funny thing is
that actually the Dart code
on the lower right
calling into JavaScript--
heck it looks nicer than
the JavaScript code does.
So--
KEVIN MOORE: In our
completely unbiased opinion.
DAN GROVE: It actually
does look nice.
I saw one guy here nodding his
head, so it does look nicer.
And the good thing is
that this will give you
a really nice experience
with all the Dart tools.
So we think we can do this
with very, very low or minimal
overhead and make it look nice.
KEVIN MOORE: So let's
embrace the web.
JavaScript everywhere,
great canonical JavaScript
for debugging, and a great story
for interop-- both JavaScript
into Dart, and Dart
into a JavaScript world.
DAN GROVE: We can actually
do better than that, right?
KEVIN MOORE: I think so.
So you know one of
the biggest things
we pushed with Dart from
the beginning-- not only
performance, but having
a great tooling story.
And so we think we have
some great new things
to show you here, and to show
you some of the directions
we're going.
The first is analysis.
So obviously anyone doing
Dart realizes the benefit
of having a full
IDE experience--
hints, warnings, refactorings.
We've done a bunch of
work over the past year
to migrate all that
to Dart so that you
can use it from Sublime,
or Eclipse, or IntelliJ
as we discussed.
But we go beyond that, right?
What's great is we're
actually in the process
of doing the work now to support
plug ability into our analysis.
So no longer will we ship-- for
instance, the Angular plug-in
as a deep part of
our Dart release.
It'll actually be a
plug-in that ships
as part of the Angular project.
And so as Angular
evolves, they can
evolve their plug-in--
and plug-in hints,
warnings, refactorings
across JavaScript, HTML.
So you should be able
to right click in HTML
and go to definition in Dart.
We think it'll be a
really smooth story.
DAN GROVE: Exactly.
One of the things that
we came to realize
as part of this
embracing the web
is that there are a
ton of other assets
out there that the Dart team
is never going to have time
to figure out how to analyze.
Right?
We're going to have
Angular, and we're
going to have JavaScript
and TypeScript,
and things like that we really
want to be able to plug into.
And so this gives us a nice
framework for doing that
and lets packages, essentially,
extend the analyzer.
KEVIN MOORE: So if you're on
our Tooling Team here today,
raise your hands.
Who's working on analysis?
Back in the back corner.
We'd love to talk to
you more about that.
We've done a bunch
of refactoring-- even
over the last week-- to
really kick this off.
And we're looking
forward to shipping
this and the start of some
of these things very soon.
But wait there's more.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
So we talked-- Lars and
Casper talked this morning
about IntelliJ and WebStorm.
And you can see the
IntelliJ booth in the back.
This is really the best of breed
for developing applications
on the web today.
And so we're in the process of
sun setting the Dart Editor.
And IntelliJ is
really a first class
way of building web applications
and will be fantastic.
It already has
awesome support as you
know-- for instance Martin could
tell you from the Angular team,
they have awesome support for
a wide variety of different web
assets.
And so we can plug into that
and we can use the Dart analyzer
there.
And it'll be a really good fit.
KEVIN MOORE: And
what's great is you
don't want us working on get
integration for the editor.
Right?
We've other smart
people doing that work,
and so we can
leverage that work.
What's great is I
actually went through this
where I was editing
a YAML file and I
didn't have a YAML plug-in.
It's like-- little
pop up comes--
do you want to install
the YAML plug-in?
And I clicked and it restarted
and now IntelliJ supports YAML.
So we think it's a great
place to better future here.
And again the way we're
building on top of it
means that the underlying
infrastructure and the plug-ins
for things like Angular
or the DDC, those
are all at the Dart level.
So regardless if you're
in Sublime, or IntelliJ,
or Eclipse, you'll still
get all those features.
DAN GROVE: That's right.
KEVIN MOORE: And we'll do a
demo of this in just a second.
But first, what's a tooling
story without great testing?
Unit test has been kind
of the package for testing
in the Dart ecosystem
for a very long time.
Must of the other
tools that exist
have ended up
building on unit test.
We realized it got
very little love.
They kind of got it working.
And then once it
was kind of working,
it really wasn't touched.
DAN GROVE: Years ago.
It got to the working state.
KEVIN MOORE: So I gave
Natalie a challenge
at the end of last year,
beginning of this year,
to see if she could do something
spectacular in a quarter.
And she's really delivered.
So starting with
[? O.12 ?], which
will be coming out very soon,
Unit Test is going away.
Now it's just Test.
The Test package will be the
future of testing in Dart.
And so instead of talking about
it, I'll show you a quick demo.
So first we'll
come into IntelliJ.
I have a test package open here.
I can do things like
scale the font size.
And the analyzer
kicks in wonderfully.
And do Command-7 to see
the structure of my app.
So you can see that the
API is very similar to what
you're already use to.
You have set up, tear
down, test and group.
The key verbs you've
already used in testing
are already there.
It's actually tough.
I want to go back and show both.
You know?
When I was on the
IntelliJ side I
could do things like Command-B
to go to the definition of map.
And I can go read
the map definition,
so it's really easy
to figure things out.
I can say, who uses
linked map directly?
And go find usages.
And get very quick dump
out of all the usages.
So the IDE experience
is really great.
And the great thing
about the Test package
that we're working on
is that it's actually
designed for toolability.
So we don't quite have a
story yet around IntelliJ.
But because it's designed
to actually have a runner
and reporter and have
these things be pluggable,
we actually hope
that integration
with things like IntelliJ
will be forthcoming.
One of the great things
is an amazing experience
running tests across platforms.
So let's run a subset of
tests from the Test package.
So I'll just pub run tests.
I got into the test directory.
You'll see there's a number
of tests here I could run.
Let's just run all the
tests in that directory.
And so you see we're
using the pub run command.
And I can get an output of all
the test that I'm getting run.
It actually supports
parallelization.
So it actually uses--
it basically decides
half the cores in your machine.
So if I say I wanted to run
-j-- --how to run tests.
I think I'd go -j8.
And run across all of my cores
when it runs those tests.
It'll fan out and do
things really fast.
But it also has
platform support.
So not do I run
on the VM-- let's
say I run it on Content
Shell, or maybe Dartium.
So 62 tests before-- uh-oh.
I did something wrong.
pub run test.
Oh, the demo gods.
Here we go.
You can see in the
background there-- so
if you watched very
quickly you should
have seen Dartium pop up.
But even better I actually
can pass in other browsers
on my machine.
This is where I get scared.
I can do Chrome,
Firefox, Safari.
And this will actually do the
work to spin up compilation--
compile those tests only once.
So it'll compile the
test once and run
across Safari, Firefox, Chrome,
IE-- If we were on Windows.
So we're going to compile
those all those tests up.
And then spin those across
all those browsers and Content
Shell and BM.
I'm going to actually
specifying in a test
and say this test should
only run in browsers,
or only run in the VM, or
only run in Internet Explorer,
for instance.
It's a really compelling model.
And the thing we're most excited
about with the test runner
is the idea that it's pluggable.
So you will be able to write
your own reporters here
to give more detailed output.
We talked to someone yesterday
about wanting to export,
I think, xunit as a format.
That'll be very easy.
If you wanted to
have a web based
runner or something
similar to Karma,
all those things
will be supportable.
So we're doing a
lot of work kind
of on the core infrastructure,
the test runner,
to make sure we nail kind
of the core infrastructure.
And once that's
nailed down we're
looking to expand this out.
We're already talking to folks
are doing things like Guinness.
What's the other one?
WebDriver and a bunch
of other things.
So I won't wait for all
these tests to finish.
But you can see we're running
across a number of browsers.
It works really great.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes.
Testing's exciting.
So find Natalie.
She's here today
and tomorrow, too,
if you have
questions about that.
So some tooling story.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
So--
KEVIN MOORE: And finally--
DAN GROVE: And
wait, there's more.
Frameworks.
KEVIN MOORE: We hear people
care about frameworks.
I personally like to
write all of my code
by hand just using Dom elements.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
I think the other
part of this is
that we've managed
to confuse people
a great deal over
the past few years
as we've experimented
with the frameworks story
and tried to come
up with a good plan.
KEVIN MOORE: Because
Angular's a great story,
Polymer's a great story.
We try to be clear about
kind of where to start.
And we've been back and
forth a little the last year.
What we're excited
about today is
to say we kind of have
a more clear path.
We can really talk to you.
So first-- it is kind of
the elephant in the room.
Right?
Angular's just taking
off like crazy.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
And not just externally.
Internally-- for instance
all of Google's ads teams--
which is-- they kind of
matter to the company.
They're adopting Angular
across the board.
KEVIN MOORE: And so
despite the confusion,
we're actually excited
of the Angular 2.0
story is meant to eliminate
a lot of confusion.
So at Angular 1
we had Angular JS,
which is a separate
project from Angular Dart.
They didn't have consistent
API's that overlapped.
They kind of iterated
to different models.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
And that would've
made it really hard
to do things like share
components between them, which
we certainly want you to be able
to do with our new interops.
KEVIN MOORE: Or
share documentation.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
KEVIN MOORE: And so despite
some of the rumors and things,
Angular 2 is designed
from the ground up
to be a first class experience
in both JavaScript and Dart
from day one.
So it's a much cleaner story.
And actually today we
were honored enough
to announce that Angular
is now in dev preview.
So the version number is not--
it doesn't really hint at it.
It's alpha.21, which is
such an exciting thing.
Someone said let's do
dev preview as a thing.
I'm like, no.
You'll break
semantic versioning,
and then you can't
release a beta.
And there's a whole
discussion about it.
So it is alpha.21, but we
are considering this the dev
preview.
DAN GROVE: Not just us.
The Angular team considers
it a dev preview.
KEVIN MOORE: Actually
even more importantly they
consider it the dev preview.
It's easy for us to get
up here and you know--
DAN GROVE: What the
dev preview means
is that this is the point
at which the first really
large scale project at Google
is starting to move from Angular
one to Angular two.
So this is actually a
pretty important milestone
for the Angular team.
And we're really
excited about it.
KEVIN MOORE: And
so before you're
used to having-- I think
there's AngularJS.org
and AngularDart.org.
The truth it's going
to be Angular.IO.
And if you go there
and click around Docs,
you'll see a drop down.
And you can drop down
from JavaScript to Dart,
and you'll see the same
documentation and examples
in either language.
So they're really trying to
offer a great story there
from day one.
And obviously, Angular Two
is a package on our pub site,
so you can go play with it now.
And then we have folks
in the room right now.
We have Tim, who's been doing
a lot of work on Angular.
And [? Jagor's ?]
here as well, I think.
DAN GROVE: Right there.
KEVIN MOORE: Yeah.
Who actually works
on the Angular team.
DAN GROVE: And Martin.
KEVIN MOORE: Oh,
and Martin as well.
This is great.
So we're super excited
to represent Angular here
and announce the dev preview.
And we think it's going to
be a great story for folks
doing a full application
framework for Dart.
DAN GROVE: Yep.
But--
KEVIN MOORE: What
about Polymer, Dan?
DAN GROVE: Well, I mean we've
done a ton of work on Polymer.
And Polymer's actually making
a lot of progress, especially
as a way of producing
custom elements.
KEVIN MOORE: Right.
I think we started talking
about this last year a lot.
We have a few folks on our team.
Jake's here.
Where's Jake?
BOTH: Way in the back.
KEVIN MOORE: Yes.
So and you might
have noticed you
know that the beta to 0.5
release last year at I/O
came out.
And then things have
been kind of quiet.
And they really did this big
reset in the Polymer world
with a real big
focus on modularity,
on kind of pay-for-play, and
on making sure performance is
spectacular.
DAN GROVE: Exactly.
So we're going to keep
following Polymer,
but one of the things
that we've realized
is that following a
fast moving project
fast is not necessarily the most
productive approach for anyone.
I mean we can
definitely do this,
but it's not really
what we want to do.
So what we're doing
right now is we're
kind of waiting for Polymer
to reach a point of stability.
And I heard from one of
the Polymer team members
at lunch that it's
fairly stable right now.
So perhaps we're
actually getting close.
But as it stabilizes, then we
will be catching Polymer Dart
up with Polymer JS.
And of course one
of the nice things
is that since it's really
producing custom elements,
and Angular is built-- Angular
Two is built from the ground up
to support that-- there should
be nice interoperablility
between these two frameworks.
KEVIN MOORE: And
more importantly--
and this is some of the work
that Jake has been doing--
is that we've kind of
refactored the Polymer
package into several things.
One of those is a web
component package.
And the idea is that
any web component
written in JavaScript-- even
if it's using Mozilla's web
component framework-- we have
a model for how you can consume
those in a Dart application.
So we really want that notion
of kind of the mobility
and the modularity
of web components--
regardless if they're written
in Dart or JavaScript--
to play really nice
in your application.
So that's a focus we've-- it's
actually been really good that
Polymer has slowed down a
little bit, or gone off,
because it's given us a chance
to really clean up our package
story.
And hopefully give you a
really functional story.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
But this isn't
necessarily-- like we
don't want this to feel like the
whole Cathedral and the Bazaar
question.
As we get JavaScript interop
working, and working really
nicely, guess what?
We want you to be able to bring
your own JavaScript library.
So we don't want
to have you waiting
for us to tell you
what frameworks
are available in Dart.
We want you to be able to make
really good use of JavaScript
libraries that are
out there without even
telling us about it.
KEVIN MOORE: And the great
thing is if they already
have type interfaces--
again, in Closure Compiler
or TypeScript-- your
Dart experience should
be something close to native
when you're using our tools.
But even better than this
wonderful six letter--
[LAUGHS]
Is this my version or are you--
did you come up with this?
DAN GROVE: I came up with that.
KEVIN MOORE: This
is the new YOLO.
It's too big for a license
plate, unfortunately.
DAN GROVE: I don't know.
California, you might be able to
get away with it, pull it off.
KEVIN MOORE: But obviously
the goal we're getting to--
and this is stuff we're
just starting to work on,
but obviously as the dev
compiler and other things
come along, this is really
the place we want to go.
Where as you should be able
to annotate your Dart code,
and say, I want to
ship this Dart code
as a JavaScript library.
And again, your
customers are people
that consume that library.
Don't need to know that
it's from Dart, other
than it has really high
quality and few bugs.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
Exactly.
Other than it's better.
KEVIN MOORE: Other
than it's better, yeah.
So stay tuned for that.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
KEVIN MOORE: So that's
our great framework story.
Angular a great
end-to-end framework
for building large
applications with things
like dependency
injection and routing.
Or tracking Polymer tightly
to make sure that once
they're 1/0, we can ramp up and
support Polymer folks really
well.
And obviously since everything's
built on web components,
we think those things
will interop really well.
And keep an eye on us
for our JS interop story.
We think that'll
be really powerful.
DAN GROVE: Yep.
Yes.
So there's a bunch of stuff
that we want you to do today.
First of all, we really
do want you to start
using WebStorm and IntelliJ.
We think that's going to
be a great story for web
development in Dart.
KEVIN MOORE: And I've been
using it every day now,
and the people on our team have.
And we really like it.
File issues-- let us know
if you have problems.
We think it's going
to be really great.
The test package-- it
leases in RC today.
So if you go to the pub
site just type in Test.
We want you to start
playing with it.
If you have test--
our code already--
already using unit
test, make sure
that you opt into it
intelligently as you migrate.
But you'll see that the
features work great.
And it's all on pub.
All on GitHub, excuse me.
So we want your bug fixes
and any issues you find.
DAN GROVE: Yep.
KEVIN MOORE: And then
obviously Angular Two,
you can put with
that today as well.
And with alpha.21, we're
now in a dev preview.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
Today's a great day to use
it, because you can go bug
[? Jagor ?] if it doesn't work.
So it'll be perfect.
And then there's a bunch of
stuff that's coming soon.
So the Pluggable
Analyzer-- tons of CLs
have been going in to
making this work recently.
JS Interop's similar.
I guess all this
stuff is red hot.
Like Pluggable,
Analyzer's red hot.
JS Interop is
definitely red hot.
Lots of changes have
been coming in lately,
and dev compiler's
absolutely like blazing hot.
There's a ton of
stuff happening there.
You can track that
project on GitHub.
It's under dev compiler
on the dartlang.org.
And you can see some
of the output that's
coming from there.
And Jacob will have
a talk this evening
to talk more about that.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
Exactly.
KEVIN MOORE: Thank you so much.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: You guys have about
five minutes for questions,
if you want to do questions.
KEVIN MOORE: That's perfect.
DAN GROVE: Right in front.
AUDIENCE: Just a
real quick question.
When we have comments or
feedback on use in WebStorm,
do you want us to file
through [INAUDIBLE]?
Or do you have a specific place
where you want those to go?
SPEAKER 1: You're close
enough that I can just
give you the mic.
AUDIENCE: When we have
issue with WebStorm,
where would you like
us to file those?
Just straight through
[INAUDIBLE] or do you have
a different place--
DAN GROVE: Yeah,
in general those
should go into the [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: And the [INAUDIBLE]?
DAN GROVE: Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
KEVIN MOORE: And
then sometimes those
end up being issues with
our analyzer, for instance,
and we're good about
shuffling those around.
DAN GROVE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great.
Thank you.
KEVIN MOORE: Make
sure you tag it.
There's actually a way to tag.
And you can tag it as a
Dart issue, if you can,
and that helps us find them.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Just tag the Dart?
KEVIN MOORE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great.
SPEAKER 1: Anyone else?
Oh, you're close too.
Oh, that's awesome.
AUDIENCE: So with
all the JS intro work
that's going to
happen, would it be
possible-- I don't know
if it's already possible
or not but-- would it be
possible to use something
like an NPM module in
a Dart application?
DAN GROVE: Ha.
You know we've definitely
talked about it.
It's not high on
the list right now.
But it is-- that's
not the first time
that question has been asked.
SPEAKER 1: I love that question.
DAN GROVE: Maybe you were
the first person to ask it.
KEVIN MOORE: So there
interesting thing with NPM,
is that we have an interop
story around the Dom right now.
But Dart I/O and
our BM story, we
have our own set
of I/O primitives.
And we don't have a support
for how you compile all of that
into things that are
analogous in NPM.
In theory, if we did you
know a clever thing--
I mean I've actually done this
with a number of benchmarks
where if all you do is
print in a benchmark,
I've been able to
Dart to JS out and--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAN GROVE: Dart
to JS [INAUDIBLE]
has always supported producing
[INAUDIBLE] compatible outputs,
so it's really a
bindings question.
KEVIN MOORE: So if you
write Dart code that
bounds to existing
node APIs-- FS
or whatever else--
those will just work.
DAN GROVE: This would be an
awesome community project.
KEVIN MOORE: Although seeing
Observatory and things,
you know I might push you more
to look at the Dart VM story.
We think it's pretty
solid, but we want
to be able to go either place.
DAN GROVE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Anyone else?
Preferably someone in
the first couple of rows
but farther back is fine, too.
KEVIN MOORE: What's great,
actually, is Steven's up next.
And he's going to talk
a lot about the Dart
to JS-- actually getting
really deep on Dart to JS.
And the interesting--
MALE SPEAKER: Don't give him too
much intro now because he's not
setting up his stuff
yet, and you're--
KEVIN MOORE: I'm
building him up.
MALE SPEAKER: But it is
going to be very interesting.
KEVIN MOORE: Right.
So thanks for your time.
Find us later tonight.
[APPLAUSE]